La volta al món a peu, dia 265, què faig a un cotxe? Avui és divendres, avui vaig dir que no gravaria, acabo de començar el dia, acabo de començar a caminar, no fa ni 10 minuts, he sortit de la casa aquesta on he dormit, de fet la casa està aquí, veieu?
Aquesta és la casa on he passat la nit, amb l'home aquell tan hospitalari, allà ha dormit. Què ha passat? Començo a caminar per la carretera i em dóna per obrir el mail. Des que tinc aquest mòbil nou, que va perfecte, m'encanta, té un problema.
Només té un problema que és que jo tinc dos mails, el personal i el mail d'Enric Adventures. El personal no se'm sincronitza, només rebo les notificacions quan em dóna per obrir l'aplicació del Gmail.
Bé, doncs em dóna per obrir-la i trobo un mail de l'ambaixada de Pakistan. Això no us ho vaig dir, però quan estava a Dushanbe, aquells dies que vaig descansar, vaig fer l'aplicació de la visa per Pakistan.
I farà que em contestessin ràpid, en dues setmanes no m'arriba el mail, no passa res. Encara no fa dues setmanes, fa cinc dies. I avui rebo un mail de l'ambaixada de Pakistan.
A l'aplicació de l'ambaixada de Pakistan deia que havies de dir on volies que et fessin una entrevista en cas...
que t'haguessin de fer una entrevista.
Jo, gent que havia vist que havia fet el tràmit aquest, doncs... li deien que sí per internet i ja està. No li deien res.
No li deien que anés a fer cap entrevista.
Però sí, sí, avui rebo el mail dient que, sisplau, avui, dia 21 d'agost, divendres, a les 14 hores, presentis a l'ambaixada de Pakistan per fer una entrevista.
Fa!
Total. Bueno, sí, vaig haver de dir que... sort que vaig ficar que estava a Duxambe, eh?
Perquè hi havia la possibilitat de... de dir que no, que jo estava a Barcelona.
Com que pensava que no em farien l'entrevista, m'ho vaig plantejar. Saps?
Bueno, si deies que estava a Duxambe, llavors havia estat presentant uns documents extras, per això m'estava plantejant no posar-ho.
I... bueno, doncs...
Doncs sí, ho vaig posar, per sort, i... doncs això, m'han de fer l'entrevista.
Que no em facin l'entrevista simplement per això, perquè estic a Duxambe, no ho sé. No ho sé.
Bueno, queden a Duxambe, vamos.
Són 4 hores de cotxe, segons el Google Maps.
I 4 hores de tornar, per tant, 8 hores. Mira, passem pel punt dels túnels.
8 hores.
Bueno, mentida, no serà tant, ara que hi penso, perquè el Google Maps...
Esteu... em veieu en fosco.
El Google Maps suposo que haurà suposat que vaig per la carretera antiga.
Bueno, és igual.
Encara que siguin 3 i pico, que és un dia sencer que perdo de caminar, és un dia sencer.
Per sort, igualment, he tingut sort perquè, això, els 10 minuts de caminar, he baixat,
hi havia una parada d'autobús, hi havia uns homes esperant,
i pregunto a Duxambe, i em diu, sí, sí, endavant.
Sabeu quan en cobren?
7 euros.
Us en recordeu? Ahir que m'ha cobrat 3 euros per 3 quilòmetres,
doncs avui 7 euros per anar 3 hores en això.
Bueno, en fi, la màfia dels taxis.
Ostres, tu, això és un inconvenient molt gran, eh?
Inconvenient molt gran, perdre un dia sencer.
Ja n'he parlat molts.
En fi, i espero que vagi bé l'entrevista.
Bueno, us veig dient.
Molt bé.
Molt bé, el taxi aquest no m'ha portat fins al 100%,
i l'altre centre de Duxambe m'ha deixat aquí una mica a les afores,
i ara m'he de buscar la vida amb un altre taxi fins al centre,
però bueno, és molt d'hora, eh?
Són les... no arriba a les 10.
Podria haver caminat una mica més i després tornat.
Ja, però i si no he trobat el cotxe i el taxi?
No, era massa risc, era massa risc.
Bueno, doncs res, aniré a un centre comercial,
aprofitaré per fer alguna compra d'alguna cosa
que podria haver comprat a una ciutat futura,
però bueno, si estic aquí a Duxambe,
ja la compro.
Entre elles, uns guants,
que tu diràs, amb aquesta calor...
Sí, però quan estigui pel Pamir a 4.000 metres,
ja veuràs quina calor que fa allà.
No he trobat els guants.
He passat les últimes hores a un restaurant en maria condicionat,
menjant i passant altres.
Bueno, aquí darrere no m'hi agrada gaire,
però hi ha l'ambaixada en Pakistan.
A veure què passa, a veure si hi ha sort.
Són menys 20, he arribat amb una mica d'antelació.
Respondré tot el que em pregunten,
amb 100% d'honestedat,
que és el que s'ha de fer en aquests casos,
i ja està. Inxal·la.
Ostres, tu mira que sóc burro, eh?
He anat a l'ambaixada que no era.
Hi havia dos, perquè era l'edifici antic,
o el que sigui, està tancat, no hi és, l'edifici,
i la nova ambaixada està a uns 15 minuts en taxi,
i no arribo.
No arribo a temps, espero que no passi res.
Si arribo uns minuts tard...
S'ha de ser burro, eh?
Aconseguit.
Ho he aconseguit, evidentment,
això d'aquí darrere no és l'ambaixada del Paquistan.
Bueno, buah.
Què ha passat?
Bueno, poca cosa.
He arribat tard, però no passa res,
perquè m'han fet esperar una bona estona,
encara que només hi havia tres persones esperant,
jo i una parella que anaven junts.
M'ha semblat que la parella eren afgans,
pel que ha estat dit por ahí.
Després de tenir-me una estona esperant,
ha vingut una persona que tenia molta cara de paquistaní,
no ho dic amb mal sentit,
però es veia que no era tagíc, d'acord?
I, bueno, m'ha dit, ara d'aquí a poc,
espera un rato, que ara vindrà el cònsol,
no sé si m'ha dit això,
però diria que ha vingut el cònsol després,
l'ambaixador, vull dir,
i, bueno, perquè semblava com una persona així més important, no?
I un cop ha vingut l'ambaixador,
simplement m'han dit, rebege aquests documents,
que és simplement l'aplicació que havia allà enviat
fa uns quants dies, revisa-ho,
i quan els he dit sí, ok, està ok,
l'ambaixador m'ha sentat allà,
jo pensava que seria un despatx privat, no?,
del pal.
Ei, què vols ser, paquistan, tal?
Però no, han sigut tots junts allà,
érem jo i la parella aquesta, però, bueno, és igual.
I li he dit, turisme, on t'estaràs?
A l'ambaixada, allà, entraré per sost,
que és allà l'aixó de Xina,
la puntera en Xina,
i, i ha dit, vale, vale, vale, o sigui,
ja no volia, no volia escoltar-me.
No, ja, jo pensava que em faria un interrogatori,
no, no, no, ha sigut, vale, turisme, ok, ok, vale,
vinga, va, ja està, ja està, ok.
Simpàtic, eh?
No dic que hagi sigut tan simpàtic,
però que no han fet cap interrogatori
que jo semblés una persona perillosa, saps?
De fet, tenia un ajudant a l'ambaixador
que a aquest sí que m'han preguntat
si jo era periodista,
perquè ha vist que tenia molts països visitats,
perquè l'aplicació de visa per Paquistan
et demana que et diguis els països
que has visitat els últims tres anys,
i en tenia molts,
i em diu, no seràs periodista?
I jo, no, no, no,
sóc enginyer.
I, bueno, m'han dit que sí, que ok,
que trigarà uns dies a fer-se,
o unes setmanes o el que sigui,
però que sí, que ho tindré.
O sigui que, perfecte, facilíssim,
una pèrdua de temps completa,
no calia, això, m'ha fet perdre un dia sencer,
i, bueno, i ara he de tornar, eh?
He de tornar.
Però, bueno, com a mínim, ho tenim, no?
Val?
Ara he de tornar on m'ha deixat el taxi del principi,
que està a l'altra punta de la ciutat,
i després allà, a veure si puc coordinar-me
amb el conductor que m'ha portat,
o, si no,
i no sé quan el cobraran.
Són les tres.
Pensava que seria complicat
tornar al lloc aquest,
perquè és un poble, parlo de la mà de Déu,
Murcià Cap o alguna cosa així,
però a la que he arribat aquí,
a l'estació de taxis que van a fora d'Uxambe,
ja,
abans de baixar del taxi que venia
des de l'ambaixada de Pakistan,
hi havia una taxista
com a lobos, depredadores,
i a la que he sortit del taxi, ei, ei, ei,
llavors,
he tret el mapa,
li he dit, vull anar aquí,
i hi ha dos que s'han ofert,
un per cent i un per vuitanta,
doncs he anat amb el de vuitanta,
vuitanta són vuit euros,
he anat per set euros,
trobo que està molt bé.
Trobo que està molt bé, això sí, no vaig sol, eh,
hi ha tres o quatre,
mira, està el taxi complet, són cinc.
Jo no ho entenc, però, bueno, ok, perfecte.
Són les tres i mitja,
mira, encara podré caminar una horeta.
Ja estic.
M'han deixat allà a l'altra banda,
i res, torno a estar
on estava fa
onze hores, onze hores.
He caminat 0,8 quilòmetres
només.
Ho he aconseguit, com a mínim, tu.
He de dir que el sistema de taxis
de Tadjikistan no està malament.
Potser el transport públic
no és el millor, no l'he provat,
però el de taxis funciona.
I ara què?
Doncs res, no sé.
No sé què fer, bueno, sí, caminar.
Una hora, no? A les set, que es fa fosc
i tal, però...
tampoc.
Tampoc sé si aquí una hora hi ha un lloc
per acampar guapos, saps? Aquí, com a mínim,
sembla que tinc
una vall, una vall així com
Planeta, que no hi ha cap casa.
No ho sé.
En fi, a veure què faig.
Vaig a estudiar el mapa. El trasllat
en cotxe, per cert, horrible.
O sigui,
hem parat no sé quantes vegades,
el taxi no portava
l'aire acondicionat, amb les finestres obertes
per l'aire de calent...
Asquerós.
Suat pertot arreu.
Molt desagradable.
He vist un lloc que podria ser maco,
potser, per acampar, amb bones vistes.
És d'aquí 6 quilòmetres,
tant un pèl fosc se'n farà,
però bueno, a més és pujada.
És qüestió de seguir la carretera i ja està.
Vull dir que, per molt que se'n faci fosc,
hi veurà igualment.
D'acord, abans, on us he ensenyat
a donar el dit aquí,
doncs allà és on vull acampar,
que és just aquí sobre, d'acord?
On hi ha les antenes de 4G,
i aquesta pista m'hi porta.
Així que pugem,
tindrem unes vistes, bon airet
i bon internet.
Ja estic aquí dalt.
Més al dalt que sembla, eh?
Des d'aquí es veu on vaig dormir ahir.
Fatal, fatal.
Sí, allà o allà.
Mira, aquí tenim les antenes 4G.
Ostres, sí que hi ha unes vistes,
però clar, es veu,
veieu que es veu com difuminat?
No?
Com si hagués una boira.
Això és per la porta.
És per la pols.
És per la pols que hi ha en aquest país,
que està l'ambient constant.
Mira, ara aquí veig el pantà.
El pantà aquest,
que us vaig dir ahir que us diria coses,
és un projecte que tenia plantejada
la URSS,
que al final es va desestimar,
però ara el Govern Tajik
ha tornat a plantejar.
I és un pantà que,
si es completa fins a la punta més alta,
que és el que es vol fer,
serà el pantà més alt del món.
Bèstia, eh?
Ara mateix no tenen finançament,
només tenen finançament per fer una part
i l'estan construint i, bueno,
aquí el tenim, aquí el tenim.
A la presa de Rogun, Rogan,
bueno, ho veureu en pantalla.
Sí, sí, doncs clar,
la carretera aquesta que vam veure l'altre dia,
evidentment fora.
On acampo? Home, aquí és el punt més alt,
està a pla, aquí el que veig
és que bufarà una mica d'airet,
però tinc més vistes.
Vaig a acampar aquí.
Veieu que està com enfonsat,
hi haurà menys vent
i una mica menys de vistes.
Però bueno, les vistes
d'aquí
tres quarts d'hora ja se'n van, eh?
Jo crec que
prefereixo tenir una nit tranquil·la sense vent,
que tampoc és que faci gaire vent, eh?
Però bueno, sempre està millor,
jo crec. D'acord, acampo
i fem resum.
Doncs avui 5 km llescats,
he parlat amb el cònsol
i el seu ajudant,
zero té, zero cafès,
dos refrescos
i m'he gastat 45 euros
avui. La majoria en taxis
i també, doncs,
alguna cosa que he comprat de menjar
i uns calçotets que m'he comprat.
Sí, perquè els que tinc ja comencen a estar
donats de sí. De cotó,
malauradament és impossible trobar-ne
sintètics en lloc, tu,
que és el que va bé per caminar avant,
és el que hi ha.
Bueno, ja...
ja res. Doncs clar,
com avui era en teoria el dia
que no havia de fer vídeo, però crec que
ha sigut interessant tot això que ha passat,
doncs serà demà que no faré
vídeo. Per tant, demà
no teniu vídeo.
Vinga, bona nit.